Could you grab that from who's having
he's going to give you something. Thank
you, sir.
[Silence]
Today is an exciting day.
Because we have completed the entirety
of the book of fasting. Thank you, sir.
You're a gentleman.
And a scholar of
home sales.
Today is an exciting day because
alhamdulillah
we have completed
the book of fasting in its entirety
from the book of al-wajeez.
And now we are going back to the very
beginning of the book.
The book of purification from
al-wajeez. We had kind of a toss-up
between al-wajeez or Riyadh as-Saliheen
to continue on that.
And an overwhelming
majority
chose al-wajeez. So, let's give it a
shot inshallah.
And
go from there be the light of Allah.
So, we are beginning
again at the very start of the book.
Usually, the books of fiqh
they
especially the later books of fiqh, the
books of fiqh that
were
written by
latter-day scholars, say
after
the fifth century.
Most of them
began to follow the way of al-Bukhari
rahimahullah in the way that he
organized his book al-Sahih
also al-Imam Muslim.
And that is that in organizing the the
books and chapters of fiqh
jurisprudence,
they would usually follow the narration
of Jibreel alayhissalam.
You know, the very well-known narration
of Umar
yaqulu baynama nahnu
julus inda Rasulillah dakhala alayna
rajulun shadidu bayadi al-thiyabi
shadidu sawadi al-sha'ri qala akhbirni
an al-Islami qala al-Islamu ila akhir
al-hadithi.
Where Umar mentioned that a man entered
the masjid that had very black hair,
very white clothing, and he proceeded to
ask the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam a series of questions starting
with tell me, inform me about the
intricacies of al-Islam.
And so he said, Islam
is to testify that none is rightfully
worshiped but Allah and that Muhammad is
the messenger of Allah, to establish
salah, to give zakah, to fast the month
of Ramadan, and to make hajj pilgrimage
to the house of Allah al-Haram if you
are able to do so.
This narration
is
usually the order that the scholars
will compile their books.
When we look back even as far as the
book of Ash-Shafi'i, rahimahullah,
which is known as Al-. He has a book
He has two madhhabs. Shafi'i has two
madhhabs. He has the old and new.
First, he went to Al-Iraq
and he spent his younger years there.
And then he moved to Egypt.
And
the opinions that he adopted
in Iraq are referred to as his old
madhhab. And the new madhhab were the
opinions that he refined later in Egypt.
Now, when those works are all compiled,
that book is called Al-.
Right? Which literally translates to the
reference or the mother book. The the
the the
reference of fiqh. And it's the first
book of fiqh in that way that we have
in in all of Islam in that way.
This even predates Al-Bukhari,
rahimahullah.
Shafi'i passed away in the year
204.
And so, we see that even he
followed that
narration roughly in organizing his
book. Al-Imam Malik, rahimahullah,
Shafi'i's teacher before him, organized
his book Al-Muwatta
based on that narration. However,
it's a little bit different.
Usually, the scholars will begin with
the book of purification.
So, if salah is the first
book that they begin with,
then purification is the first
of that subject.
Others began with the
chapters regarding the times of prayer.
Right? Cuz salah isn't really obligatory
until the time comes in.
And that's how Al-Imam Malik
Rahimahullah organized his book. But,
they all pretty much followed the way of
the scholars of Hadith in organizing
their books. And that is based on this
narration, the narration of Jibril
alayhis salaam. They begin with the
pillars of Islam. And then they follow
that up with the rem- remaining
books and chapters regarding worship.
And then after that, they branch off
into al-mu'amalat and so forth. And
this book is no different. As we've
mentioned before, this book al-Wajiz,
it is really
a summary, an abridgement
of
the book
Fiqh us-Sunnah authored by Sayyid Sabiq
Rahimahullah. He was a very renowned
Azhari scholar.
And he wrote his book Fiqh us-Sunnah
roughly, I think, somewhere in the
1950s or '60s, somewhere in there. He
continued to refine it. And there was
kind of a an explosion of
writing
going on in Al-Azhar. And there was
almost a knowledge revolution
during that era in in modern
history.
And so, he wrote his book Fiqh us-Sunnah
as a very summarized book.
It's in three volumes. But, one of the
reasons that it caught on so much and
that it is so ubiquitous, so well
well so widespread,
even though the books of fiqh, if we
were to enumerate
all of the books of fiqh ever written
in the history of Islam,
I mean, we're talking about
hundreds of thousands of books have been
written on the subject of fiqh.
however, his book
became very, very popular, very, very
commonplace, very, very well known.
And one of the reasons is that his book
relied so heavily on referencing the
evidences from the Quran and the Sunnah.
So, he would not just mention one
particular madhhab, he would not just
mention the conclusion, but he would
mention the evidence for that conclusion
from the Quran, from the Sunnah, and he
draws from all of the major madhahib and
the major books of fiqh. And it became a
very good beginner's book
into the field of jurisprudence. If a
person wants to
get into the subject of fiqh in Islam
and they want to have a good foundation
to start on, Fiqh us-Sunnah would be a
very good choice for that. And so,
al-Wajiz is a summary
of that book, more or less,
in that
the author removed
many of the arguments, many of the
peripheral issues, many and he kept the
evidences from the Quran and Sunnah.
He'll mention the issue,
then he'll mention the evidence from the
Quran and Sunnah.
A A of times when
we go to learn something fit,
people become very very
unsure. They become very dubious with
respect to fit. Why? They say, "Well,
there's so many madhahib
and there's many different schools of
thought and
what madhab is this and what madhab is
that?" And this really is an issue
of conceptualizing fit to be this
monstrosity of a field in which
everything is a difference of opinion.
Nothing is agreed upon. Everything is a
difference of opinion. Nobody really
knows what's going on. It couldn't be
further from the truth.
The majority of Islam and the majority
of Islamic law
is agreed upon.
Where Where is the difference of
opinion?
The difference of opinion comes to play
with with respect to with respect to
details.
Right? With respect to details.
For instance,
all of the madhahib
hold the
opinion
or it's not an opinion or
upon the
understanding that
purifying a person's clothing from any
filth
is a prerequisite to salah. It's part of
the rulings of salah.
If there is some najasa
on a person's clothing,
that this would more or less invalidate
a person's
salah until they purify it. Okay.
Where is the difference of opinion?
The difference of opinion comes to play
with
to
the details. How much of that is
acceptable? How much of that is
overlooked?
what about if a person only realizes
that they had najasa on their clothing
after they've already completed salah?
Right?
Or
what is the bare minimum?
What is the maximum?
These are the things that they differ
upon, but the issue itself is agreed
upon. And that is what this book mainly
focuses on. Doesn't focus on the
details as much. It focuses on the
direct commands that come from the Quran
in its most obvious of interpretations
and the Sunnah and the most authentic
and obvious of narrations.
Beginning with the book of purification.
The book of purification.
He said, "Purification in the Arabic
language
is that a person purify himself
or purify something from
any type of hadath.
Hadath
is something that
is
a form of
a form of imperfection. Something that
would make a person undesirable or
imperfect.
And in the language and terminology of
the scholars of fiqh,
jurisprudence,
at-taharah, purification,
is that a person
enter a state
where salah is permissible.
Or that a person
remove any deemed filth from their body
or clothing or
place of salah.
So, this is what this book here is going
to
explore.
Number one, raf' al-hadath.
Raf' al-hadath,
which is that a person
enter a state of spiritual purity
that would make
salah
permissible.
So, is it permissible to make salah
without wudu?
What's the answer?
No. So, it's haram, right?
Is it haram to pray without
wudu?
Huh?
It is haram, right? Okay, so this is
what we call a hadath.
Right? This state of impermissibility,
this is referred to as a hadath.
And
taharah, which when we say wudu is a
condition of salah,
that's correct and incorrect at the same
time. Why? Because it's not as precise.
Wudu is a condition
of salah for a person who has access to
water,
for a person who can use water,
for a person who's not in a state of
major hadath,
right? Meaning that he needs to bathe,
is in a state of minor hadath, then yes,
wudu.
However, if a person is in a state of
major hadath, he could make wudu all
day, and he still wouldn't be able to
pray. He has to bathe.
And if a person has no access to water,
then for him, wudu is not a condition of
salah, rather it is tayammum, right?
So, more specifically,
raf' al-hadath is a condition of salah.
So, this book is going to deal with two
things. The book of purification. It's
going to do deal with two things. Number
one,
it's going to deal with
how a person goes about entering that
state
of purification
that makes salah halal for them.
That makes salah permissible for them.
The second thing this book is going to
deal with is
purifying the clothing,
purifying the body, purifying the place
of salah from an-najasat,
from that which is deemed to be filthy.
Because not everything is filthy. Some
things are unclean,
but they're not necessarily filthy,
right?
So, for instance,
filth an-najasah
is
let's say for instance, urine is a type
of najasah. This is a type of filth.
It is filthy and it's unclean.
However,
say for instance,
snot,
snot from a person's nose, right?
Is that
a type of filth?
No, it's unclean.
But it's not a type of filth.
Filth means that you cannot pray with
this on your person, on your body.
Right?
And we will get into the distinctions of
those things in sha Allah
So, it's very important to understand
these these two things are what this
book is going to deal with.
Number one, Rafa al-Hadath.
And that is that a person
you know, that a person
enter into a state of spiritual purity
to be able to pray.
To be able to make tawaf around the
Kaaba.
To be able to handle the mushaf.
You have to have purity for that.
Spiritual purity.
Either by wudu
or ghusl or tayammum.
And number two,
this book is going to deal This book,
meaning the book of purification, is
going to deal
with
listing the various types of filth
the various types of najasat and how a
person goes about purifying those things
and what things need to be purified in
order for a person's prayer to be
acceptable.
And we will begin that in sha Allah
[Arabic recitation]